I
welcome everybody to our weekly
conference and today's speaker is known
probably to just about all of you dr.
Michelle rye bar who's going to talk
about work that she's done dr. bribe our
originally received the PhD in computer
science from Northwestern University and
then joined our faculty and she I guess
I can take responsibilities suggested
that you should become a fellow and get
formal training and informatics and
actually that worked out really well
because she's just recently awarded the
kind of Cadillac of career development
awards the k99 our double zero so we're
proud of her it didn't hurt that we just
submitted our competitive renewal for
the training grant and could amply brag
about that and they design challenge and
and all the other great things that
she's done so I will let her take it
from here good morning and thanks for
coming and today I'm going to be talking
to you about the secondary use of HR
timestamp data for include improving
clinical workflows so before I start
though I wanted to thank the people and
funding that has made this work possible
namely the ophthalmology department here
at ohsu and demise dr. michael chang who
has helped advise this project and sarah
r e brown and david meerman who have
worked on a data analysis and
simulations and the clinicians who open
their clinics to us for observation and
study and the funding that made this
project possible so today's doctor
struggle with efficiency they are
pressured to see more patients in less
time and unfortunately the EHR has
become a kind of a sources its
inefficiency a lot of them feel like it
slows them down and studies at KCI
Institute have shown that post EHR
implementation the patient volume went
down and but you know in clinics have
used different strategies to kind
overcome this inefficiency they've added
ancillary staff to do initial exams but
now patients may see multiple staff
members in addition to the provider
they're often shuffled between exam
rooms and there really isn't any
guidance for providers as to which
patient to see next if there's a group
that are waiting in terms of you know
which is the most efficient to see next
and it can feel a lot like there's all
these moving parts with knowing
coordinating it and yet another airline
industry metaphor for this but sort of
like you're in an airport with all these
planes taking off and landing and
there's no air traffic controller to
kind of coordinate the whole thing so
and of course inefficiency causes
patient wait time and it's well known
that patient wait times are a
significant driver of patient
satisfaction which is a really important
metric for outpatient clinics but
additionally patient wait times can
actually become a barrier care patients
won't return for follow-up visits if
they expect long wait times so the way
we're trying to address this it's
building models and we're using
simulation models that can test
different clinic configurations to see
if we can make them more efficient
without having to do tests and use
clinics that sort of guinea pigs
themselves so we can do this using the
computer and you know for these models
we need different types of information
we need input about you know helping
patients are scheduled how many
resources are being used and resources
would be things like staff members exam
rooms that sort of thing we also need
data about how long all the different
steps of the workflow take and we need
large amounts of this data because we
have to represent the variability that's
inherent in all clinics but if we have
all of this the models can run and they
can give us output that can give us
answers about essentially how long were
patients waiting how long did the clinic
take how well how much were all those
resources the staff the providers the
exam rooms being used
so this is where the HR timestamp data
comes in while the HR can actually be
contributing to this clinic in
efficiency we want to see can actually
use the HR to actually improve processes
can we use data from it and most of us
are used to the secondary use of EHR
data relating to clinical research or
quality metrics but there's actually the
HR is actually a really good source of
timing data because almost all recorded
information in the hrs time-stamped so
if we can mine this data and we can find
you know essentially how long things are
taking in clinic then we have a really
good source for our models for that
large data so the very first thing we
did was to look at the workflows the
clinic make sure we understood them and
then validate the data from the EHR to
make sure that it matched our workflow
so we studied for outpatient clinics and
ophthalmology for different
subspecialties we chose ophthalmology
because it's a fast-paced specialty
combined medicine and surgery and the
clinic workflows are actually multiple
stage and complex we observed each of
the four clinics for at least four half
days to see what the workflow was and to
actually take timing measures so we knew
how long each of the steps took then
once we understood that then we went
into the EHR to look for timestamp data
that matched it and then validated to
see how close we got to our observed so
the first thing we did was we determined
what the workflow was for the clinics
and as it turns out for each of these
four clinics it's very similar we're
actually studying a fifth clinic where
the workflows a little bit different so
that'll probably be a future talk but
this is you know patients come in they
arrive they check in and then they go to
the waiting room to wait for the exam to
start and at all these clinics they used
ancillary staff and sometimes it's North
optus sometimes its attack that does an
initial exam sort of is the initial you
know examination of vision or of the
eyes and after that exam the patient's
eyes maybe dilated
if they're dilated the patient's return
to the waiting room so they free up that
exam room while their eyes are being
dilated and dilation usually takes about
20 to 30 minutes and in each of the
clinics the frequency of dilation varies
so in some clinics it's almost all of
the patient's eyes are dilated and other
clinics very few of them are but once a
dilation is done or once that initial
exam is done if the patient's eyes
weren't dilated then they're ready to
see the physician and they're in the
exam room waiting for the physician
physician examines them they return to
the front desk where they check out an
important thing before I got going to
mention is in between that initial exam
and the finches position exam the staff
members have to complete documentation
from that initial exam because it's used
by the physician during their evaluation
okay so then we went to the HR we went
to the ohsu epic data warehouse to look
at what timing information was there and
what we could get that matched our
workflow so first of all the check-in
and check-out times our events that are
recorded in the eat-in epic and are very
readily available we did find however
for one of our clinics that the checkout
time wasn't reliable in that clinic the
patients aren't required to check out at
the front desk before they leave so the
front desk staff just checked them out
when they notice that they're gone some
cases it's when they leave some cases
like three hours later like wait a
minute what happened had the patient all
they're gone so we can't you we couldn't
use that time stamp however we know at
the end of every exam the after visit
summary is printed so we could use that
as a surrogate for the end of the exam
for the both of the exams the initial in
the patient-physician exam we used audit
log data so audit logs are required by
all electronic health records that
record essentially what's done by anyone
who's in the HR in they're time-stamped
so we were able to use contextual data
about the patient and where they were in
terms of the you know which
professionally we're on to figure out
when which timestamps occurred with the
patient in an exam room with a staff
member or with the physician and we just
looked at and we found the first one and
the last one and then took the
difference and that became the length of
the exam the dilation information is in
a template in a smart form in epic and
so we were able to get from that
information whether or not the patient's
eyes were dilated and if they were at
what time so once we had all those
pieces then we could figure out exactly
how long the patients were waiting and
notice they wait essentially in two
spots either for the first exam or for
the physician mixing so when we compared
them to the EHR when we compared the HR
timings to the observed well over fifty
to sixty percent of the exams fell
within three minutes of the observed
time so they were actually pretty close
the where they didn't match were that
some of the staff and some of the
clinics once the patient the initial
exam is done and staff remain in an exam
room and do their that documentation
that has to be done before the physician
exam and so when we went through the EHR
it was very difficult for us to
determine when the patient left you know
and when they were just doing
documentation so for those cases the
staff initial exam was overestimated
however the documentation time is part
of our workflow and is going to be part
of our model so in some sense it doesn't
matter if it's counted as per the exam
or is a separate step so but remember
for our simulation models we really want
a large amount of data we want the data
to represent the large variability that
occurs naturally in a clinic over time
so we wanted to look at a year's worth
of EHR data and see how does it compare
to what we observed is it are we in the
same ballpark and so what we did is we
just looked at density plots of both of
those sources the red is the EHR data
and the bluish green is
served and in most cases there's a lot
of overlap and overlap is what we want
we want it to be representative it's
going to be a little bit different
because the ends are different for one
thing so we do expect with the EHR
having a much larger n that we'd have a
lunch larger variability within the EHR
and there is just some that's a little
bit different depending on the
documentation patterns of the staff
members but this overlap indicates
promise that we can use the CHR detik
data for our models so that leaves us
two steps to which is building our
simulation models and what we used was a
simulation called discrete event
simulation and what that is is it breaks
down any process into a series of
discrete events or steps and each of
those steps takes a certain amount of
time if the step takes a constant amount
of time that's easy you just put that
into the constant however in most
processes the individual steps say like
the initial exam or the physician exam
or variable they're going to take a
variable amount of time and so what we
do then for that step is represent that
time using a probability function and we
can base it probability function on the
data that we get from the EHR and as you
can see here this it we use a arena
simulation software by rockwell
automation to do discrete event
simulation because that's sort of
relieving software tool for des but the
other parts of the simulation are you
know it's sort of like a flowchart so
there's decision points so for example
we'd have the diamonds there for
decisions like was the patient violated
the patient's dilated it goes down this
path if they're not goes down this path
so it's sort of like just a giant
flowchart and you just go through now
because there's so much variability and
because each time we go through this
like will will simulate a clinic and
we'll have a patient come in and they
sample from the probability distribution
you know how long that initial exam took
how long the rider exam time we have to
run the simulation multiple times to get
a good idea of what the behavior is over
time and how that variability effective
time so this isn't something you just
run once we run it hundreds or thousands
of times to get a good idea of how the
system behaves so going back to our
clinics just as a reminder we sort of
have three big steps where we need data
and where you know sort of most of the
work is happening and that's at the
patient arrival and the two different
exams maybe it's still have other things
happening like documentation or dilation
but those aren't as big and what we
really needed our data for from the EHR
was to represent the variability of the
patient arrivals and the exams now the
patient arrivals and in these outpatient
clinics all the patients are scheduled
so we're not trying to model say for
example the variability of a walk-in
clinic where people aren't scheduled you
don't know who's coming when however in
our model we didn't want to just take
the data of you know all the arrival
times and then plug that in because our
model we would actually wanted to see
and play with the scheduling so what we
did instead was we did a combination we
looked at both when they were scheduled
and we didn't want to use just the
schedule times as when the patients
arrived because that doesn't represent a
real-life system at all because anyone
who works in clinic or his bending
clinics knows that patients never arrive
at precisely the time that they're
scheduled right so instead what we did
was we measured the Delta so the
difference between their arrival time
and their scheduled time and we use that
as a probability distribution and we
added that to their schedule time so
that's how that was modeled and then we
just had probability distributions for
the two different exams and the other
thing that's important in simulation
models are the resources so each of
those steps that happens in discrete
event simulation has a time but it also
has you know what is it using the system
and the resources in our system are
people in exam rooms we didn't get at
the granularity of modeling any types of
equipment or anything cuz most cases
those equipment belong to the exam rooms
so in our case our exams both take a
person in an exam room okay
and the waiting or the queues happen
when patients are ready and are there
but the resources are busy so either
there isn't an exam room open for them
to be seen in or the person the staff
member or the provider is it ready to
see the patient so there's actually two
possibilities for weights ok so we build
a model for each of the four clinics and
we modeled a half day clinic ok and to
do this for each of the clinics we
needed information about that clinic and
we were able to get it from both the HR
data and from interviews with clinic
staff so the types of things we got from
the HR data were the things I've
mentioned so far so you know what was
that a rival Delta distribution what are
the exam distributions what how long
were staff spending doing documentation
is between the exams and you know how
frequently in our patients dilated other
things we got from interviews so you
know talking to the clinic stat clinic
staff you know how many ancillary staff
members do you usually have during
clinic how many rooms are you using how
many patients are typical during a
crafted clinic and even though we did
interviews with staff members we still
validated a lot of these values from the
HR because it turns out if you want to
find out exactly you know on average how
many patients are being seen in a clinic
and a half day the worst thing to do is
to look at someone scheduling template
because we've got these templates and
then found out when you looked at the
EHR and saw actually you know who
actually showed up is that the templates
to give you kind of a starting point but
for some providers their templates are
never filled so they never fill their
full day other providers have the
template and says you know we're going
to see 10 patients you know in three
hours but actually they saw 18 and so
they're always overbooking so we had to
use kind of a combination of what the
clinic said and then what the EHR data
told us to determine exactly what all
those different parameters were for the
clinic's then we ran each of the models
a thousand times and the metrics we were
looking at for validation were you know
are we in the ballpark for the exam
times what we
expect to kind of give us a you know
sanity check that these are working and
the patient wait times later on we're
going to be looking at different output
metrics from the simulation models so
these are the four clinics and we
compared in this case the distributions
of the exam times so the red are the
exam times that we got from the HR the
green were the ones that we measured and
you sort of saw that before and then the
blue represents the exam average exam
times that the simulation model giggles
okay and if you look at the between of
the red and the green they're kind of
what we expect the Reds are you know the
red values are a lot broader have more
variability than the green do there's
one clinic where there's a shift here in
glaucoma and that's do that's because we
were over counting the exam time with
the staff members because they were
doing the documentation there but with
the blue the reason that the blue is a
lot narrower than the other ones is just
a sort of an artifact of the limitations
of simulation model when we were trying
to get data from the simulation model
about you know what was actually going
on the only data with the granularity we
can get at was the average exam time /
clinic day replication so we weren't
getting the actual exam times for each
encounter and if you you know statistics
when you plot distribution of averages
as opposed to the raw data the
variability is much narrower approaches
normal so that's why those are more
normal but what we're looking for is
overlap and you know kind of convincing
ourselves that were you know
representing the system at least
somewhat and then we did the same thing
for wait time so the wait times
overlapped a lot more and it's sort of
the similar type of thing looking at you
know the difference between the EHR the
observed in the simulated data so we
have some confidence at least for the
proof of concept that you know we're
getting close so we wanted to use these
models to start answering questions for
the clinics and oftentimes clinics one
of their first strategies for addressing
in
is to say hey can we add more resources
can we add more staff can we add more
exam rooms is that going to help us and
so what we did was we ran the models for
each of the four clinics using different
numbers of staff and different numbers
of exam rooms and what we found out was
there was a big decrease in weight time
when we went between one and two staff
members or one into exam rooms there was
a little bit when you went from two to
three but after that you can see it just
completely flattens out and the reason
for this is that once you get you know a
couple of staff and two or three exam
rooms those resources no longer become
your bottleneck the bottleneck is
actually your provider but the way that
clinics are essentially defined in
ophthalmology is that it's one provider
in the clinic so it's only we can add
more providers and what can happen is
that when you start adding more staff so
let's say you have four staff members
anything oh I can see four patients at
eight o'clock in the morning while those
four staff members will see those four
patients and then all of a sudden at
eight-fifteen the providers got four
patients waiting for them so the patient
that provider really becomes a
bottleneck so because the clinic's we
all looked at we're already using at
least two staff members and at least
three exam rooms they showed you know
the clinic managers there's no benefit
to try and improve efficiency by adding
any more resources and in those areas so
instead what we focused on which is a
third part of this is how can scheduling
how can we do different types of
scheduling and how can that address our
inefficiency and approve rate times so
clinics will tell us and we've observed
this ourselves is that clinics you know
any particular half a clinic session
there's going to be spurts where they're
the clinics are very busy there's a lot
of patience and you might have like four
or five patients waiting for a doc and
then there's going to be times when you
know the provider doesn't anything to do
because all the patients are either
being seen in their initial exam or in
the waiting room being dilated so you
kind of have these fun
it's punchy and so what we're trying to
do is see you know there are outpatient
clinics the patients are scheduled we
have some control about when they arrive
can we make them arrive in a smarter way
so that there's a more steady stream of
patients so we don't get this bunches
and we have less wait time so from the
literature we know that scheduling
patients according to length and
variability can actually improve wait
time so if we know which patients are
going to take longer we can actually
schedule them smarter so that they're
not disrupting everyone else because if
you have a long unexpected long
encounter then you get behind and then
you never recover okay so we went back
to realized okay so our age our timing
data give us information about exams but
we also have data about the actual
patients themselves and what was done
during the encounters so can we connect
the information to be able to predict
who's going to take long can we figure
this out so in the case of the pediatric
clinic we were able to identify both
looking at the EHR data but also talking
to clinic staff because clinic staff
know you know which patients take longer
is that the new patients take an average
longer than a returning patient the
other thing they were able to tell us to
was that their child patients take less
time than there are dolt patients do and
it may seem strange that pediatric
clinic sees adult patients but pediatric
ophthalmologist street mr. business and
so if you're an adult that had
previously untreated store business as a
child you're going to go COPD pediatric
ophthalmologist so they already had some
sense and we can see we can already
identify pretty sabino easily that
there's a group of patients here that
are going to take longer so if we know
this then can we do scheduling a little
bit better so the other thing we wanted
to look at was what's the impact of
these long encounters on wait time and
on a clinic day and so you know there's
going to be a certain demand for long
you know for these patients are going to
take a long time you know for give it a
given month or a year or whatever than
that or whatever it is but if they're
not scheduled in a smart way you can
have clinic
days that might have 10 long encounters
and some days that don't have any so we
looked at the the data and found out
that there's a big range between how
many long encounters actually appeared
in the clinic day for each of the clinic
and the resulting wait time was really
dramatic you know sometimes it's two or
three times the amount of weight time
that you would have with fewer long
encounters so if we can limit the number
of long accountants / clinic session to
be some value that's going to you know
still meet demand but just kind of
regulates it so that you have less
variability between days we thought that
would be a smart strategy now the other
thing is where do we put these long
encounters once we have them and this is
hard to see but what I wanted to show
you is it for all of the clinic's the
patterns were there saying so you know
if we put them at the beginning of the
clinic we reduce the overall clinic
length but we increase wait time so just
to give you closer up so you can see
better and this is sort of
counterintuitive to what a lot of
clinics already do so a common
scheduling strategy for clinics is to
put the long patients the ones are no
there and take longer at the beginning
of the day because they want to get them
out of the way and they don't want them
to unnecessarily extend the length of
your clinic okay but and we can see that
if we look at the orange line you can
see that and along the x axis here is
where the position of those long
encounters so one would be at the
beginning of the clinic day and 13 would
be at the end so when we put them at the
beginning of the day you can see that
the clinic links is minimized but the
blue which is a wait time the clinic the
patient wait time is actually maximize
and what happens is when you have long
encounters especially ones with big
variability at the beginning of the day
you pay clinic commissions often get
behind and they never recover and it
just sort of snowballs more and more
people are there and more wait time more
longer queues so the closer we can get
them to the end of the day the less they
those long encounters
impact everyone else's wait times okay
but this is the nice thing about the
simulation models is that we can present
graphs like this to the clinic managers
because it's not clear necessarily that
you'd want to put them at the very end
of the day to minimize wait time when
it's going to you know unnecessarily
sort of lengthen your clinically so
these you can give this information to
the clinic managers and they can make a
decision as to where to put them well
maybe it makes sense we'll put them in
the second half of the clinic but maybe
not at the very end so we don't have a
really long clinic day then the
pediatric clinic asked to refine this
strategy a little bit more and this is
based on their own intuition and some of
the practices that they're already doing
in clinic so what they wanted to do was
they wanted to bend the patients into
three categories instead of just long
and regular so they wanted the short
patients and the reason for this is that
they were already sort of ad hoc
managing the short patients on their own
so they weren't necessarily scheduled in
any slot but when if you had a group of
patients that were waiting to see a
provider they would just naturally take
the next patient that they thought was
going to be the fastest and get them out
the door even if that patient hadn't
been there as long as some of the other
patients does that make sense so they're
kind of letting people leapfrog because
they know they're going to be shorter so
if we can identify those short patients
and put them at the beginning of the day
get them out of the way their neck never
going to wind up in a queue they're
never going to be wound up being
impacted by someone who's longer then we
can start you know decreasing average
wait time for everybody else the other
thing that they asked was what happens
if we put a blank slot in the middle of
the day that allows for some ketchup
here it is that going to decrease our
weight or patient wait time and so we
went back to the simulation model and
ran it and said okay well what happens
if we have no blank slot which is the
first point up there and then what
happens when we start scheduling that
slot and you know at the first slot
second thought and so on and we found
that the minimum was at blank slide
10 okay and so that's what we did and we
have been testing it in clinic since
then however we don't have a lot of data
yet because it's really difficult to to
come up with these testings and any
short notice so they did free up when we
initially started testing they'd free up
a day like in two or three weeks they'd
add another clinic and but the problem
is that you can't get a good mix of
patients in just two or three weeks you
know lead time that when you know
especially an ophthalmology clinic where
your patients who come in regular
library three months or six months you
really need to have those days kind of
far in advance and be filled more
naturally with the general mix of
patients that you would normally have so
we're still working on testing this but
so far we've had two good days of half
days that we've been able to test it and
the average wait time was significantly
smaller than our observed days are nine
of half day clinics that were similar so
we think that this has promised and
we're going to be continuing to touch
that we had a test day this week in
mulva testing next week and hopefully
we'll get more data as to how this is
performing so but of course anytime
you're working with a schedule
especially a schedule that becomes more
and more prescriptive it becomes more
and more difficult to schedule because
you know patients don't always are
always available when you want them to
be and they may want different slots and
so we've gotten a lot of comments from
the schedulers you know one thing is you
know I need more slots for what we
consider the medium encounters I'm not
filling the short thought what should we
do so we use simulation we treat them
out a little bit and said okay well you
can put the medium patient in this
particular short spot and it will only
you know it shouldn't impact the system
too much the other big question they had
was you know where do I put urgent
patients so I have to if I have to
double booked someone where do I put
them and we thought well you know just
put them that Bank blanks lot well we
ran the simulation models and actually
what it showed was
it didn't matter and I think it's
because our schedule was already sort of
optimized and once you put him in the
bank slot they were already doing catch
up during that period so it really
didn't decrease wait time to put him in
that blank slot versus double booking
min another [ __ ] the only thing that it
showed was there was a slight decrease
in weight time if you put them at the
very beginning of the day or at the very
end of the day but it sort of reassured
them you know yes you can put an urgent
patient where you'd like with the
schedule and it shouldn't have too much
of an impact well it does have an impact
but it doesn't change that impact
doesn't change based on where you put it
so this work has some limitations that
we're still working on the EHR
timestamps really can't capture in some
cases the full length of the exam time
because you know staff or providers will
have portions of the exam that happen
either before they first use the HR or
after they stopped using the HR so we're
looking at different ways within the
answer are different reports that that
might get around this a little bit the
other thing we're looking at is doing
some automatic data collection might be
better at getting more exact exact times
but the other big 12 is that we have to
be able to predict which patients are
going to take longer which patients are
going to be shorter in order to
implement these schedules that we've
defined and it's really easy in a
simulation model to say okay this
patient is going to be sure it will put
them here and we're in the model but you
know how do we know who's going to be
short how do we know who's going to be
long so we've done some initial work on
this but it's actually pretty tricky
because there's so much variability in
these exam times that there aren't a lot
of big things that pop out as being big
predictors of somebody who's going to
take longer we know that new patient
take longer we know certain diagnosis
will take longer certain procedures like
dilation may take longer in the case of
the pediatric clinic we know that ages
can take longer but really through our
observations and through in talks with
different clinicians a lot of times
the things that fact that that sort of
make and encounter long are things that
we have no data about there's nothing in
the EHR that tells us when a patient's
going to be chatty and so how do we
address that so we did a study a few
years ago where we looked at we observed
in clinic and we looked at the different
exam times and then saw and broke them
out depend on these different categories
and so this was in the pediatric clinic
and the blue bar represents the provider
the orange is the tech and the green is
the North optus and so the tech and Eric
Baptists are the ancillary staff to do
the initial exam and the basic
difference between them is that the or
thought disease patients that have
strabismus and the tech sees patients
who don't so anytime you see a green bar
essentially you're looking at strabismus
patients and the orange are everything
so you can see that for example the one
in the middle is age you can see that
the toddler's not surprisingly take a
lot longer for the provider and the
adults do as well you can see that
violated exams no this is just the exam
itself not the time that it takes to do
the dilation but once you're with the
provider and you have dilated eyes the
exam actually takes longer doing a
different type of exam in new patients
take longer but one of the things that
we did is part of the study is we wanted
to see because the providers identify
which patients were going to take longer
and so we called it complex as opposed
to taking longer and as it turns out the
patients they identified as being
complex and this could be complex based
on a diagnosis or just on the patient
being chatty and as it turns out the
ones i identified is complex were longer
so this indicates just that writers
really can identify in our good source
of information and so because we already
know that the new patients are going to
take longer and those are sort of the
unknowns we just put them in the lawn
encounters but anyone that's a return
patient the provider you know has a
follow-up form and they have on that
form you know what slot they think that
patient will need
when they're scheduled next and so that
can be based on the you know type of
exam that's going to be next or can base
be based on the patient so that's the
way that we're hoping that we can
address this problem so in summary we
have been able to show that the EHR can
actually be used as a tool for improving
clinical fishin see it's not just the
maligned you know thing in you know
that's ruining the clinicians efficiency
we showed that our simulation models can
be very effective they can be used for
testing different clinic configurations
different types of resources and we can
provide clinic managers with information
that allows them to make smarter choices
about their clinics how many resources
how they want to schedule people and
where and these report results appear to
be generalizable for the four clinics we
looked at now granted they had similar
workflows but all the models showed
essentially the same patterns what
happens when we add more resources you
know after a certain point there's not
much of a return when we put the long
encounters in different spots for all of
the clinics you know it increased wait
time the earlier there were in the
clinic but it decreased the like clinic
length so this sort of you know gives us
some confidence that these results
aren't just unique to a particular
clinic and might be generalizable even
outside of these ophthalmology
outpatient clinics that we looked at and
it really broadens the HR into tools
that can be used for workflow
improvement so that's it if you have any
questions or comments I'd love to talk
about this with you
you know that's really great work
because there is a lot of that timestamp
data that's available you know one of
the things that I didn't hear was
provider inter variability is that
something you looked at at all I mean
some providers are going to be much more
efficient than others and you know maybe
the ones that are inefficient need more
time in terms of what we were just sort
of measuring how long they took so we
weren't necessarily comparing them to
one another or seeing what that impact
was on the overall workflow so we
weren't really trying to identify and I
think this is it we sort of did this
from the beginning sort of to gain
confidence in to gain collaboration is
that we didn't make it about staff or
the providers trying to evaluate them as
to whether they were taking too long or
too short right we were saying okay this
is a given this is we're going to
measure how long you take and given that
this is how long you take can we
schedule people better so I don't think
we have plans to start looking into that
because that's not but I think there are
other people in kc n studio that are
addressing that problem a little bit
more directly I would um do you want to
talk about some of the stuff that Sarah
I mean um you know Michelle home or in
terms of what you're talking about
Michelle's work with someone named Sarah
Reed Brown who had looked at yes there's
yes ok there's back there who looked at
sort of how long each provider takes
documenting and that's not exactly the
same as what this but it's very closely
with its efficiency fastest is seven and
a half minutes per patient slowest is 45
minutes per patient now they are they're
very different types of medicine that
they do but but they're there i agree
with you that there are huge
variabilities here
you've probably considered that um you
were looking at patient variability
primarily and then you ask the providers
to sort of predict who's going to be a
quick and slow patient um but you
probably consider that elsewhere in the
medical record you have lots of time
stamp data in that slow patients in the
ophthalmology clinic tend to be slow
patients in the dermatology clinic and
the internal medicine clinic and that
might be a source of predictability yeah
and we are looking at you know sort of
past exams as predictor we hadn't really
looked outside specialty however but
that's a good point that it would be a
way of doing prediction especially for
patients that maybe hadn't been in
ophthalmology for very long so you can
yeah so you can look yeah that's a good
point in your simulation are each of the
distributions for the events separate or
is there some covariance in between
there and this is kind of getting at
like if you have a slow patient they're
going to be slow in each one of these
yeah and that's a good point no right
now they're they're independent which
isn't necessarily the case because the
well they're sort of independent so if
you're a long patient you have separate
distributions for the initial exam and
for the provider so they're they're
dependent in that way but you don't have
within that category you're not trying
to connect the initial exam to the you
know and there are is a lot of
covariance that's a good point we
haven't figured out how to manage that
yet but yes you're right because it
really wouldn't be realistic that if you
had you know a really long patient that
somehow when you do that initial exam
you sampled something that wound up on
the shorter end and yeah so we're
looking at different ways of doing that
and we did do something initially we
were submitting up patients based much
more fine-grained and so they were more
connected but those models were much
more difficult to manage and especially
when they translated and scheduling a
lot more complicated for someone to
managed so we're going to have to go
back and figure out how to make them a
little bit more fine-grained I think
epic has two levels of audit trails
there's a standard level that's turned
on all the time in all clinics for all
providers it's mostly for compliance
purposes there's a separate additional
level that you can turn on it's much
much more data intensive which of those
have you been using just the regular not
the not the dating since right right
okay and have so follow-up question then
if you thought about looking at that
additional level of audit trails in
order to get more granular information
yeah we did get some of that data
initially and it was a lot more
difficult to deal with because it didn't
have didn't connect as well to like the
encounter and so we could match up
exactly what was going on with that
particular patient and where so no we
didn't at least for that particular data
the other thing is you have to turn it
on and we could do it but we wouldn't be
able to do it for a really long period
of time so we sort of sacrificed that
you know instead of looking at you know
over time and being able to get a year's
worth of David yeah that makes sense you
definitely can only do it for like a day
at a time right exact right here it's
time right sometimes two at least
validate your more generalizable tool
that can be helpful if you consider
doing RFID tracking of patients again as
a as a sort of a gold standard automated
way of validating it yeah we're actually
considering not using that but I beacons
and using you know some sort of iOS
device where they would go and they be
tracked that way it's we've done some
testing with it and have had some issues
with its kind of difficult when you're
trying to get at a granular level where
everyone is and you have a bunch of
sensors and they wind up competing with
each other so you think you're someplace
we're not so we're still working on that
work so since that I get is that you're
using wait times as sort of a surrogate
for overall efficiency are there are
there reasons to believe that that is a
great measure of efficiency or and are
there other ones and then also are there
measures of I guess clinical outcomes or
or affect you know effective treatments
and stuff like that that's a really good
question the other things that we have
considered using besides just wait time
would be things like you know what's the
maximum size of the queue for example or
what's the utilization of the providers
or the staff members because all of that
gets to you know are you using you know
our people were being busy most of the
time the wait time was just the one that
was the easiest to determine from the
simulation models and to compare to what
we could get from the HR data is a way
of validation we're still working on
some of those other ones but they're a
lot more complicated to try and and and
see the other thing that we're hope that
I've been wanting to do for a while is
actually creating data visualizations of
an actual clinic day so you can actually
see these patterns and see you know
what's going on with efficiency is wait
time the best one or are there other
triggers that we can see earlier that
are going to you know show us when we
start getting off track but in terms of
the clinical effectiveness so we haven't
looked at that yet but that's really
that's a good point if I can just add to
your response on that the wait times in
clinic have traditionally been used as a
marker for efficiency and also are very
very strongly related to patient
satisfaction and other clinical outcomes
as well as cost issues in clinic what's
interesting though is that it's largely
around how you manage patients
expectations so if you update them every
couple minutes that it's going to be a
delay their perception of that weight
changes dramatically so there are
operational things that you can do to
change the impact of that way time
exactly and it's sort of like you know
Disney is the master at this right
because if you think about when you go
to Disney
Disneyland the majority of your day you
are in line but you are the happiest to
be in that line than you'd ever be in
your life so you know part of this
research we think eventually will wind
up being something like that words
information that's both given to the
provider and to the patient about what
the current status is the metric of wait
time is a very standard one but it's not
necessarily one that's very actionable
right so how do we figure out when in
the clinic and what can we do to adjust
in real time and so those are all the
things that we're looking at in the
future to try and make this more
operational so by any chance did you
consider the no-shows in the clinic
where did you observe any patients who
cancelled yeah well they're always
no-shows um and that always impacts
things and so what we did was I had
modeled it two ways which is you know
looking at the template and what we
expected and then adding the no-shows is
a separate kind of rate and or looking
at the data and looking at over time
what that variability was in terms of
the size and measuring it that way and
it just turned out easier to look at it
from instead of modeling it as a no show
just looking at it as you know the
numbers that actually showed up that day
which is essentially the same thing but
that's one of the things that we're
looking at two how those no-shows impact
and you know and then how the urgent sim
packed things too so how do those
balance out in fact a weight or an
actual clinic day and what the wait
times are ya have you ever have you
thought of doing a comparison study with
the VA no
well the interesting thing about the VA
that I think would be an interesting
studies from what I understand and maybe
I have this incorrect but is that they
will have some of their clinics will
have multiple providers in the clinic
and so when you show up for that clinic
you may not be there to see just one
particular provider and so what's nice
about that that's sort of a different
there's different kinds of models for
service and queues and this is sort of a
different model where you have kind of a
group of people that are providing the
service so when you show up you see the
provider who's ready next so that's sort
of a different model from what we're
using but it's an interesting one
because I think in a lot of cases that
winds up being a lot more efficient than
when you just have one provider / clinic
I would like to add something to the
initial question and comment by the
previous commanders is that there are
some other metrics that can actually be
tracked based on improving the clinical
workflows and some of them could be
access are looking at the backlog and
also the third next available
appointment so just getting a bigger
picture of things would be could be the
next step yeah and that's one of those
are some of those factors that we've
been using in some of our other studies
to try and kind of understand the
overall picture of what the patient
volume is and when patients are seen and
what that overall wait time is not just
within the clinic itself
I'm actually wondering if I could ask
folks like maybe Rob and Tim because one
of the questions about this is sort of
what's the next step in other words how
do you integrate something like this
into the real world and what I sort of
i'm thinking two things in particular
one of them is that to query data we
meaning somebody like Michelle or sarah
has to query it you know from the data
warehouse and secondly to integrate that
with a scheduling system you know we
have to you know it's a very manual
process right now and if we were to try
to like if Michelle were to take that
next step and you know how do we take a
system like this that she's been
developing and get it into the real
world with epic or maybe with other ear
jars in some kind of generalizable
manner what is the strategy that
Michelle should take you know with that
is it you know working with some kind of
API to interface with you know EHR
scheduling systems in general or how
should how would you suggest that should
work let me think about that I think
you're getting the data from clarity is
that right if you want something more
real-time you don't have to go out to
chronicles directly and we have done
that I Kaiser Permanente and we get data
probably every five minutes and we're
able to build a dashboard of what's
happening in the clinic so that would be
one approach I can put you in touch with
it with the person that did that work to
follow up on the Homer that's a great
point in the emergency department for
example now it's calculating wait time
in the emergency department in real time
and displaying that to provider so when
I'm in primary care clinic and I want to
think about sending a patient to the ED
it says the wait time for adults is
three hours and 42 minutes and the
doernbecher children's emergency
department wait time is two minutes
basically I sent all my adults to join
Becker so there are ways to build it in
as a real-time feedback loop there's
also a whole bunch of opportunities with
with ap is to pull data out
even out of Chronicles feed it into an
external system run your algorithm there
and then through datalink feed it back
in 2 chronicles in more or less real
time or at least maybe like 15 minute
increments can I raise one other
question do you mind going back to those
slides with the you know those slides
yeah the ones with the wait time and the
clinic length yeah one goes up one goes
down because I mean this is a question
that Michelle had talked about and we
had pondered for a while that the way
that the metric of mean wait time is
defined is that the mean weight time of
all of the patients in the clinic and
one thing that we wondered about is that
if your patient if your long patient
goes in first it affects every other
patient and so by definition it seems
like there's an inherent bias that if
you schedule later you affect less
people there for you impact the mean
weight time less and so I we've never
really been sure if this is a fair
metric for representing you know the
impact of a long patient on the clinic
and so I'm just wondering if people have
ideas about what a good sort of unbiased
metric would be for calculating
disruption you know in his mean wait
time the best you know given that you
know we're dealing with this temporal
issue that you know the earlier you
place them the more people you that
delay percolates down to yeah I think
what would be more interesting to me is
knowing you know finding out what's an
acceptable way time and then what
percentage of patients are beyond that
mm-hmm right exactly because you're
still going to have potentially patients
in here that have very little wait time
in some
more that's a good idea do any of these
clinics I know some clinics at ohsu now
have a whiteboard and they put a
expected wait time and I know adminius I
think might open up my lap and start
working then I'm what strated it a long
wait already told oh right yeah they
some of them have those up but I don't
know like do you know how those are
determined or yeah we've never figured
that out yeah that's my yeah at least
within the department of family medicine
clinics the nursing staff of the MAS
that are working with the providers have
a pretty good feel of how many people
have checked in what type of complexity
patients are they get to know them they
know the you know whether it's the
provider who's a chatty provider and
it's kind of like the restaurant maitre
d use like oh yeah you have a 45-minute
wait for your table and they're pretty
accurate in that guess so there's
there's no formal metric behind it but
you kind of know how long your provider
is going to be and then in most of the
primary care clinics now they do have a
whiteboard in the waiting room that they
update pretty frequently to let people
know and as I mentioned earlier that
does make a quite a bit of difference in
terms of patients willingness to sit
there and wait yeah so I I thought this
was really interesting what you
presented and it got me thinking a lot
about how like efficiency is measured
and what the gold standard is because I
get the impression that like the
providers who are able to run through
patients very very quickly throughout
the day or like the gold singer like
everybody should be like whoever but I
also wonder if there's like a certain
level of inefficiency that's actually
necessary and you'd mentioned for
instance you had mentioned earlier that
like the slowest note writers are like
45 minutes and like well is it because
they typed seven words per minute or is
it because they're writing like small
books for every patient and then your
shortest ones are like seven minutes and
is that because they can type at 150
words a minute or is it just because
they don't document
and so I think there's a lot of other
examples but like is is like schedule
efficiency like the is that like the
thing that we should be going for is are
there other like measures that can be
incorporated into that it's a really
good question and there is inherent
differences between people and how long
that they take and yeah that's a tough
question and one that we've asked a lot
you know how do you represent what
efficiency is and you know if these
discrete event simulation models are
typically used a lot for like
manufacturing processes where you have
you know a bunch of equipment and you
know these little parts or widgets are
going to go from you know equipment to
equipment and you know they're measuring
efficiency by you know things like
utilization of the machines and what the
output is you know how many widgets can
they turn out and give it another time
and in clinics it's a little bit
different um you know we could use
patient volume but sometimes patient
volume isn't necessarily representative
efficiency but it's maybe you know the
providers preference because each
provider has a different preference for
how many patients they want to see and
some of it might be limited by their own
capabilities and you know how quick they
are with different things or how long
they want to take with patients so yeah
it's really tough so you just run up
another issue that I think is
continually interesting to me and how
healthcare industry is being compared to
manufacturing and I'll be damned to
compare my patients so like you know
like an automobile processing plan or
something like these are people and so
it's really hard I I mean like I'd also
dare to say that health care is unique
in this sense and it's not at all like a
lot of other sectors where we can just
like assemble right boss no it's totally
different and and just because you know
the discrete event simulation models are
used for manufacturing doesn't mean they
can't use for health care but it means
that your interpretation of what they
tell you is different because it's not
the same
and and in some cases you know is it
really bad that some providers take
longer with some patients and the others
and sometimes it's good so you know
trying to figure this out and you know
even identify what's good versus bad
it's hard it's complex or not always one
answer but we're just trying to you know
provide data and provide information to
people so that they can actually see you
know what's the effectiveness what's the
impact and make decisions and make more
informed decisions than what they had
before which is just sort of ad hoc you
know well you know if we have patients
waiting you know we'll take the one that
we think it's going to be the quickest
first well then that's the case if we
can figure out who those quick patients
are maybe we should put them first
anyway so just trying to you know get
these things a little bit more
operational and give them more
information to make better decisions but
certainly not trying to make them into
manufacturing plant that's not at all
riffing off that just a little bit as I
remember your plot overlays where he had
the distribution of your model versus
observed versus EHR timing data I think
the model had pretty fair central
tendency agreement but the overall
variability was smaller did you play
around with the parameters at all that
affected variability for the model to
see if your predictions were robust to
that variability we did a little bit but
as I explained you know unfortunately
the what we're showing here for the
distribution for the simulation model is
not exactly the same as for the others
these others are representing the actual
variability between encounters so each
raw encounter exam time or wait time but
for the simulation and this is sort of
eliminate the limitation of our model is
we couldn't figure out how to get the
exam time for every single encounter
that went through our simulation model
so instead we're getting summary
statistics we're getting an average for
each replication so when you start
plotting the distribution of averages
you're going to get something with you
know but at least the central
and see matches but the variability is
going to be smaller and more approaching
normal because that's what averages do
does that get at the fact that there's
probably many many more variables in a
real clinic that affect those the
variation and that versus a scenario in
the simulation that has a handful of
variables yeah the simulation models can
only go so far I mean even when we use
the probability functions based on the
data I mean we sort of have to you know
identify which probability distributions
and which parameters and you know
they're still not going to match our
data exactly so there's going to be some
mismatch there but then there's all
sorts of things that happen in clinic
that is just almost impossible to
represent in our simulation model at
least very efficiently or effectively so
you know for example in our simulation
model if a patient arrives let's say
there are three hours early and they
arrive in our system there's still the
patients are prioritized in the order
that they arrive so if you have a
patient that's supposed to come you know
love and clock shows up at eight you're
going to take if the eight o'clock
patients they are you going to take the
eight o'clock patient first however what
can sometimes happen in clinic is that
the eleven o'clock patient shows up at
eight even if they're ready and you know
that there's you know staffer physio
writer isn't busy they're not going to
take that patient right away because
they're waiting for their 815 patient to
show up in there 830 patient and they
don't want that eleven o'clock patient
to kind of get in the way and so that
kind of decision making is a little bit
harder to represent in the simulation
while it'll come up with absolute rules
that are going to apply to every
situation so there is a little bit of
mismatch and so there's always going to
be times when they don't exactly
represent what happens in clinic
okay the question that was brought up
and just what was talked about oh sorry
found it so the one is how do we model
if you on your previous scrap you were
showing with the two axes the the
relationship between dependence between
the people the patients will come in the
clinic and that to me is a Markov
process and the time that it you can use
a hidden Markov model and the latency
could be the time that they're in the
clinic which it then is predicted but
through going to the model so that could
be the dress that way and also how you
just brought up it's more complex of
what if a patient comes in in the middle
of that's again another type of Markov
model which can have multiple right so
and also the things like that will also
get at giving you better confidence
intervals for your graphs that gives you
better like you don't really know if
that actually is a real separation you
know giving you a difference in time or
not right so those work kind of relating
to all those thanks yeah thank you for
coming
you